what's up jujubes it's your boy at the
qsc
test your strength to schedule
our schedule is mad strong bro yeah
analytics says that's a bad thing
i'm finding my footing all right that's
enough andy's healthy
oh god so you'll notice these little
fishies are in cover wood will paint
nothing else peyton manning is speaking
hell yeah i'm gonna encounter so much
space oh man
i got disgusting damn pc culture
listen up everyone as john mara owner of
the new york football giants i believe
football should be classy and boring we
have to obey him because his grandfather
bought a football team in the twenties
taunting must be stopped so we need
someone who's not afraid to hunt for
calls sir i heard you all need a problem
song but i finally won
really come on guys i'm good at figuring
things out now couldn't have been julio
you only taunt if you could find the end
zone this is true which brings me to the
panthers people think i'm good enough to
taunt sam what were you doing near the
ride i had to leave the fun house
because i wasn't used to having fun and
that's when i saw a figure i swear i saw
a real person
why would anyone do this did they take
out his ankles again worse he's got a
sprained heart it's our first league man
it's impressive to see a man feeding off
his emotion yeah i know you're having a
moment but i'm doing the detective thing
this time very well the taunter should
strike next there
makes me sick to see players speaking
their minds you can be good at [ __ ]
both i can't my sources tell me the
taunter is still on the wheel
the
yeah
of eyeliner go come on derek you are
built to reach great heights
i know it's you
you broke my heart
spider
to why
banana hell yeah it's me man tom ross
stupid man football supposed to be ready
i can't take you down we have a good
relationship now ah
man i love this skidman
goddang chargers man
you know this reminds me of a wild
training camp story about jim hersey and
sea bass and a bottle of tequila can
everyone of the carnival please shut up
this man is trying to fish joining us is
special guest jay cutler jay you like
hunting and fishing yeah yeah oh sorry
jay one of the fish is making a run for
it